welcome to cloud minute today I'm going
to show you how to create a bucket in
Google Cloud storage using the Google
developers console here's a project I
just created here we see some get
started options including create a cloud
storage bucket clicking this brings up
the cloud storage browser which is found
at storage cloud storage browser in the
left nav bar since this project is not
of any buckets it prompts us to create
one select create a bucket here we enter
our bucket name bucket names must be
unique across all projects if I try to
create a bucket with an obvious name
such as demo I will be told this bucket
name is not available there are rules
belt bucket names that I'll talk about
in another cloud minute but if you stick
with lowercase letters numbers and
dashes you'll be fine the Create bucket
dialog is quite helpful here I've typed
cloud - and it tells me bucket names
must end with an alphanumeric character
I finished the name cloud minute demo
and click create my bucket is created
and shown in the cloud storage browser
with the message there are no objects in
this bucket we will see how to upload
objects to your bucket in another cloud
minute I hope you found this cloud
minute helpful